Tomica is everyday a writing day for you
actually know it's funny because most
most writers will say you have to write
every day you have to write every day
and for a time I used to do that and but
it was journal writing everyday journal
writing everyday journal writing and
then I would be inspired and I'd write a
project a screenplay a poem whatever it
is but I came to a place where there
were so many other things going on I
knew I had to experience life and
journaling became a different thing it
was more like where I would just vent
and I got to a really peaceful place in
my life where I didn't want to vent in
my journal anymore so I stopped writing
in my journal which when I think about
it sometimes and I look at my journal I
oh well I kind of regret doing that
because there was also kernels of just
what was happening in my life you know
sort of a chronicling of my life but I
really admire writers who literally
commit to write every day if I were to
give someone advice I would definitely
tell them to do that but I also know
that everybody has a different process
and when I'm inspired literally it just
all comes out so like even my first
screenplay I thought about it for two or
three months and then literally I wrote
it in like three weeks so when that
happens when I'm inspired like that and
I've been literally thinking about a
project and sort of letting it marinate
it just all comes out so I say everybody
has a different process but I would
probably have a lot more product if I
just committed to write something every
day it could be a poem it could be
anything I think that's just really
wonderful to do but have so many
different interests that writing is one
of them so yeah so when you do write
what does a writing day look like I'd
say in my most prolific time a writing
day is literally getting up in a very
discipline way and writing for four or
five hours or more straight I would get
up and consistently go to
shops and maybe show up around 10:00 or
11:00 a.m. and I'd start writing you
know I you know mess around on Facebook
or whatever and then after I'd
procrastinate it for 30 or 40 minutes of
it like okay you got to get to it now
and so then I would write for about four
or five six hours maybe take a break and
have some lunch and then I'd write again
until like late in the in the evening
and then I'd go to the gym go home and
do it all over again and there were like
very specific coffee houses around LA
and there would just be the usual
suspects so you'd see other writers
screenwriters you'd also see like maybe
students but mostly after a while you'd
see the same kind of screenwriters and
there was one guy who was a storyboard
artist and he was getting into the whole
digital thing and so he would be there
every night doing his storyboard art
digitally or whatever and we would all
that we'd like all know each other so
we'd have to sometimes find different
different coffee shops because it would
become slightly more social like okay I
don't want anyone to talk to me right
now cuz I really just want to focus and
you weren't distracted cuz I just tried
to go to a coffee shop to try this hole
and couldn't do it there was no way I'm
too either with too many things I was
watching well um I wasn't distracted
because I get distracted at home because
there's too many things that I can do at
home if I'm in an environment where
everyone's really just doing their work
and writing it's hard for me to be
distracted I'd say the thing that would
sometimes distract me is if they were
playing 80's music all the time like
I've been like okay can they really just
finish with this cuz I'm gonna sync to
every song I can do it's about playing
all the 80s I'm like I love karaoke so I
really I feel like okay fill my blood
okay oh my god another plague that
benatar oh my god now they're playing
and I would sing to all of them so I was
like no I need you guys to finish that
or I put in my earphones and you know
zone out on some classical music or
something that was more like background
music as opposed to something that I
would literally want it like singer move
to sounds like the energy of being out
really kind of invigorates you it does
it does and I and I will say there is a
collective consciousness of work focus
so if you have four or five people who
are really writing in an environment and
you know they're screenwriters and you
know that that's what they're doing
you're gonna kind of feel compelled I
feel or at least I did I felt compelled
to really write you know and I'd say
okay you need to do at least ten pages a
day you know and ten pages seems like a
lot but I would take the pressure off of
myself by saying they can suck but you
still need it didn't they do the day
yeah now is a lot of this journaling
sort of like artist pages sort of the
artists way were you just like getting
out all this stuff that's swirling in
your head um I would say it is kind of
stream of consciousness maybe more so
stream of consciousness for the
journaling when I was going to the
coffee shops I wouldn't journal I would
just do my screenwriting work so that's
when I was saying I would do ten pages a
day when I'm journaling it's just stream
of consciousness and now I do it at the
end of the year so my I guess some
people would consider boring process is
I will like you know do some prayer and
meditation whatever and I will literally
write for like a day and a half so I'll
write like thirty or forty extreme of
consciousness pages about everything
that happened that impacted me during
the year so it's literally like a 30 40
page journal that happens over the
course of a day and a half and then do
you burn it do you keep it I know you've
had your journal taken there any still
feelings about that like someone might
read this you know no the only time I've
ever burned my journal was
and I had a boyfriend who read it and I
was just being dramatic and I was like
you read it now I have to burn it no
okay
I just for theatrics yeah exactly
you